phenotracker is a deep phenotyping
platform that helps generate continuous
high throughput data
to characterize disease and intervention
in the next few minutes i will share
with you
what the platform does why it was
developed where we are in its
development and what it can achieve for
drug testing and repurposing
disease in humans is well characterized
mainly because doctors are continuously
monitoring patients
such data allows us to see variability
in disease stages levels of severity
understand how these influence outcomes
and study treatment responses
such detailed clinical information has
led to a paradigm shift in medical
practice
and clinical trials stratification of
patients
personalized medical treatment and
precision molecular diagnostics that
accompany treatment selection
animal models on the other hand which
are critical to advance
compounds into clinical use often do not
reproduce accurately such detail
for example animal models and experiment
factors are typically selected
for lethal endpoints rather than
examining natural variability in stages
of disease progression that are observed
in humans
natural manifestation of disease in
small animals is not well defined
and many questions that would be
important for treatment
go on unexplored leading to course
observations at the same time close to
40
percent of candidate compounds failed to
become drugs in part due to the
bottleneck of preclinical development
during this stage researchers study
compounds that show efficacy in cell
lines or organoids
to understand efficacy and toxicity at
the biological system level
which has complex metabolism immune
responses and
tolerance for both disease and treatment
interestingly
over 60 percent of animal models used
for such
testing are mice rats or other animals
such as
hamsters or ferrets to address the
challenge
of detailed disease monitoring and
quantification of drug responses in
pre-clinical animal testing
we developed a platform for deep
phenotyping
and deep learning it is an alternative
to an
all-present doctor that sees each animal
individually 24 7. importantly
such high throughput data acquisition
from animal experiments
often fails due to instrument complexity
and high costs resulting in short-term
observation studies
with limited sensitivity to account for
long-term trends in animal condition
physiology
without significant invasiveness that's
why the system that we built
is a balance between ease of use cost
effectiveness
scalability and long-term monitoring
capabilities
phenotracker is a tracking and analysis
platform
that is designed to collect continuous
data from multiple
sensors and extract characteristics of
animal physiology
body vitals behavior and even the
underlying
state the animal is in powered by deep
learning
the system provides real-time alerts
extracts
meaningful trends and data and brings
the lab experiment within reach
for researchers that are not present or
not able to be in the lab
when the animal is showing important
changes associated with the studied
condition
that's why the way the system works is a
combination
of hardware optimization and software
designed to reveal important information
that is not obvious from
short-term observation real-time raw
data using thermal and infrared sensors
are captured and sent to the cloud for
processing
there each animal is analyzed for
posture changes
speed of movement and other features
including
advanced seasonality decomposition and
deep learning
here on the left you can see the
captured information
after body detection and on the right we
show how
each 10-minute interval of video is
analyzed to reveal patterns
using multiple data points ultimately
these vary significantly between
pre-infection
and post-infection conditions something
that might be easily missed
if you were to look at the cage for just
a few minutes
once the data is acquired from a sensor
it is separated into individual features
normalized and prepared for comparison
from user-generated metadata
to capture changes in amplitude and
periodicity
we separate the trends into individual
segments which are compared to the
baseline
of the individual animal during the
healthy stage before the
start of the experiment then data is
analyzed for variation from baseline and
used to train a predictive machine
learning model
that incorporates system dynamics into
its prediction of outcomes
on top of this process we developed a
software layer to provide real-time view
of raw video stream
process data as well as custom alerts
for anomalies and state changes to help
incorporate such insights
into experiment design and intervention
additional tools for big data analysis
allow the user to compare and contrast
the data from a given experiment
to accumulated data sets in our
proprietary database
of animal phenotypic patterns the
interface helps bring
the experiment to the user making it
possible to view
explore and run big data analysis
interactively in the cloud as well as
explore the results of this analysis
in comparison to ongoing experiments
that are being conducted
as a result this proprietary high
throughput data can be used
to train a predictive model of animal
disease progression
that allows a detailed analysis of
phenotypic and molecular data
to extract biomarkers associated with
pathogen type
stage of disease progression treatment
response
recovery rate and even population
dynamics of animal to animal interaction
or disease spread continuously
monitoring these conditions
and changes for each stage animal
and organ molecular profiles using
rna-seq
can show how the body reacts to
infection what types of pathways are
activated
and how this can be used to describe the
biology of infection
that drives disease progression our team
has been working on several different
prototypes
viruses vaccines and treatments working
with labs
at university of california san
francisco
tulane university and louisiana state
university
we tested and refined the hardware for
use in biosafety level 2
and biosafety level 3 facilities develop
solutions for different animal models
designed and tested our software with
lab technicians and research users
and as a result we have collected data
on enteroviruses
covid19 compared routes of infection and
now
we are testing interventions for
efficacy and toxicity
in the next six months we plan to a
complete ongoing experiments and publish
findings with our research collaborators
b develop several more cages based on
demand from partner labs
and test new sensors for specialized
experiments
c ultimately we plan to demonstrate how
this type of data can be utilized for
basic research
drug testing as well as characterization
of treatment response to optimize
and shorten preclinical testing in
reality there are so many unknowns about
disease and animal models
and if we are to use animals responsibly
and understand how these biological
systems can mimic
human disease and help us develop novel
interventions
we have to develop a model of
personalized disease dynamics
high throughput data and precise
understanding of how disease
develops will ultimately open the door
for new treatments
new knowledge new capabilities our goal
is to make this platform a standard part
of all
animal experiments and a major component
of animal testing
together with our collaborators we are
working on a number of high impact
projects that include source code two
treatment testing
a variety of vaccines as well as
experiments that can help
optimize intervention timing and prevent
transmission
we believe that this technology is a
powerful platform for pharmaceutical
model of drug discovery
testing and drug repurposing with so
many companies turning to ai
guided drug design analytical drug
repurposing models and discovery of
novel
compounds phenotracker is a competitive
advantage
in the hands of experts with insights
into animal condition
testing strategies collected baseline
data
as well as the capability to help design
novel sensors that provide
unique insights into the many aspects of
health
and disease thank you for taking the
time to learn about phenotracker
the studies i described today were done
in collaboration with ucsf
tulane and lsu and we're funded by darpa
nih and nsf grants for any additional
questions
feel free to reach out to me elia
pine.bio
or visit our website fino.tracker.com